meine damen und herren in diesen stunden
erreichen uns furchtbare und grauen der
regener aufnahmen aus der ukraine wir
sehen dutzende erschossene zivilisten
buch da ein gebiet nördlich von kiew das
bis vor wenigen tagen vom russischen
militär kontrolliert worden ist straßen
übersät mit leichen notdürftig
verscharrt körper
es ist von frauen kindern und alten die
rede die unter den opfern sind
die ermordung von zivilisten ist ein
kriegsverbrechen
diese verbrechen der russischen
streitkräfte müssen wir schonungslos
aufklären ich verlange dass
internationale organisationen wie das
internationale komitee vom roten kreuz
zugang erhalten zu diesen gebieten und
die gräueltaten dokumentieren die täter
und ihre auftraggeber müssen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden
der krieg in der ukraine befindet sich
in der sechsten woche tausende
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sind ihm
schon zum opfer gefallen und das töten
geht unvermindert weiter
ich fordere präsident putin und russland
auf endlich in einen waffenstillstand
einzuwilligen und die kampfhandlungen
einzustellen
es ist ein furchtbarer ein sinnloser ein
durch nichts zu rechtfertigen der krieg
der unendlich viel leid erzeugt und
niemandem nutzt er muss aufhören
wir werden im kreis der verbündeten in
den nächsten tagen weitere maßnahmen
beschließen präsident putin und seine
unterstützer werden die folgen spüren
und wir werden der ukraine weiterhin
waffen zur verfügung stellen damit sie
sich gegen die russische invasion
verteidigen kann